[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
this is where we find ourselves with
elon musk about to buy twitter yeah i
saw that apparently it's going down it
happened oh [ __ ]
what oh [ __ ]
the press release has been announced
elon musk just bought twitter we got a
movie star
type of a superhero it's like a movie
like if you had a movie and there was a
guy who was like a like a hero in the
movie who happened to be a billionaire
does wild [ __ ] like makes his own
rockets and drills under the city and
electric cars
insane elon musk agrees to buy twitter
in a 44 billion deal you want one of the
most successful humans in history
especially in the tech sector to be on
the board of an app he's the best
twitter account
yeah so of course you want that guy
representing your brand and he's not as
dangerous as like a trump was you know
trump's twitter was awesome yeah like he
doesn't have the same radio activity
it's controversial but it's not the same
yeah that's the guy that should own the
majority of twitter twitter's long been
a [ __ ]
it's long been a [ __ ] um
and so
i hope elon flushes it look it'll change
everything and i wonder how quickly uh
it is before donald trump's back he said
he's not coming i think he'd i already
saw a thing he said he's not gonna come
back even if elon bought it i didn't see
a reason why but that's all right i'll
tell you exactly why because of his
truth social
um social media why are we playing
around with this twitter [ __ ] will be on
truth social is that big that's donald
trump's social media is it is it big the
biggest is it it's the best
it's the biggest
the biggest of all time
they say that twitter's not as big
donald trump says i'm not going back to
twitter even with elon musk taking over
donald reconsider do you think he'll
bring bring trump back and let trump
have his
well first of all trump trump publicly
said he doesn't want to be back on
twitter so oh yeah because he has the
truth on uh yeah his own thing he's
promoting it's like taylor marjorie
green wants to be uh get her a [ __ ]
uh personal account reinstated sure you
think he'll do that
probably yeah i think everyone should be
able to be on there dude i that's where
all my heartache is twitter so i never
look at it it's gross
it's disgusting my biggest it'll ruin my
day but don't you think everyone should
be allowed to be on twitter yeah i don't
understand like who who gets to decide
what's a [ __ ]
what's good to put out to the world
there's so much [ __ ] on there anyway
the weird thing to me about kicking
trump off twitter was even if you
[ __ ] hated trump more than anything
in the world okay yeah you hate trump
fine i understand
there's [ __ ] porno on there yeah but
there's girls spreading their [ __ ] my
little kid can scroll and watch a girl
farting come out of her butthole on
twitter but you don't want this psycho
on there what's the difference but it's
the guy is the girl farting calm
starting an insurrection she might be
there's all this uh big talk about like
what does this mean and elon musk has
put out a lot of information saying
about a lot of um
quotes a lot of like statements you know
about he wants to be an advocate for
free speech he wants this to be the
place where like you know you could go
on and say anything and do anything for
you know free speech purposes and uh you
know
and you know how do i feel about that i
mean i i kind of felt like that thing
was like that already
and then you have these like you know
uh fox news sort of people who were like
you know elon musk is going to be able
to control the information he's going to
turn down the algorithm for you know
certain candidates and all this kind of
stuff and i thought to myself
weren't they sort of doing that anyway
or they could have been doing that
anyway so the first thing i want to talk
about is like you know people are making
this big deal about this guy owning it
right but who owns it already
who owned twitter who was in charge who
was making choices who was the person
that made the choice that trump for
instance had to be taken off twitter who
makes the choices for like their
policies about hate speech and uh
who they're taking it off like how come
nobody was concerned about who was who
owned twitter before that i hear they're
gonna put an edit button now because
that was one of the things that he
suggested and he made a poll do you
think twitter should have an edit button
and he said yes
who edits what you whether you can edit
it like you write something and you
write 1945 but you meant 1965 like [ __ ]
you have to delete the tweet and start
all over again and he wants the he was
like
made a poll should twitter have an edit
button and the vast majority of people
said yes so let's see if they implement
that he's trying to get an edit button
and he's trying you know he's got some
concerns
about the draconian
uh policies we're seeing on a lot of
these tech sites good for him yeah he
wants to open source the algorithm
uh what does that mean speak english uh
the choice of uh which algorithm to use
or not should be open to everyone
interesting so you could go on what like
a hate timeline you go i want to go on a
hate timeline today you could curate
whatever you want to say you could
curate whatever you want so it's just
not only twitter feeding it you can feed
yourself
you can go i want to go on a timeline of
just celebrities and shootings
i want kardashians and school shootings
today that's my mood
i want to oscillate between meaningless
celebrity gossip and the bodies of dead
children
you can pick and choose you can curate
your timeline i want a little queuing on
today
i want a little queuing on today and i
like some motivational uh
speaking
i want some bitcoin and q
i want a little q and a little coin on
the timeline today that's what my
timeline is it's just bitcoin
trans people
ever and and uh q anon related
activities that is my entire twitter
timeline it's bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin
trans trans trans i like one thing that
he's trying to do is he's trying to
verify every person yeah so we're gonna
make sure they're humans yes and i think
that's great because it's like all these
bots are what create these stories and
create all this outrage that's what has
[ __ ] russia and all these other uh
countries trying to interfere with not
only our elections but our like just
discourse in general like you're making
it look you're putting gas on a plane
when it's like if you contract every
single twitter account back to one
person yes and verify them you started
with amber i mean i knew this before
amber heard just because what happened
people have actually done this to me but
uh all of this the stuff that was that
was going on negative about johnny depp
it was like 11 of that [ __ ] was like
eleven percent of the pro
amber her tweets were boxed so they were
basically set up taylor so they were
basically paying for yes their campaign
anti-johnny depp [ __ ] you can do that on
twitter you can do that on twitter and
youtube for sure you know all the social
media talk reminded me to let you guys
know joke world has a dope instagram
page for real we're featuring a new
comedian every day 60 seconds of
material that they send in trying to get
their jokes seen on a bigger platform so
even if half of the people watching this
message right now could just go over
click the link in the bio follow our
instagram it would really give all these
comedians a bigger platform to get their
work seen we're trying to create
something really cool in the comedy
space something that hasn't been done
before and it's all in your hands so
please go follow the instagram we're
saying everyone free stickers when you
do and by the way subscribe to this
channel while you're here and we'll get
back to the video elon musk what
happened to the tunnel he was building
between what happened to the tunnels has
he given up on the tunnels
remember when i was on rogan and we were
talking about these magical tunnels the
elon musk why don't you build a tunnel
under austin to help the traffic except
the tunnel doesn't you go underground
and you never come above ground the
tunnel just leads and it just drops you
into some like hole in the ground that
you can never come out of how about that
be a great tunnel but i guess we've
given up on the tunnel the ambitious
tunnel system that was going to get rid
of traffic um and there's the mars
expedition but now he's buying twitter
which i'm for
i like the idea that he wants free
speech back on twitter but i think the
better idea is to just shut twitter the
[ __ ] down
that's everybody's real take that really
thinks about it the best thing to do
would be to stop trying to make
meaningful arguments in 140 characters
or less
get the [ __ ] off it and move to one hyde
park in knightsbridge
and if you can't do that kill yourself
because there's nothing else to do maybe
pollux peak in hong kong perhaps but the
language barrier is something it's not
nothing over there but that is also i
guess and there's smog ice cubes show
support he said free at last elon musk
take off my shadow band homie you wow
did he just call martin luther
wow
ice cream
is cute what's going on brother
now that is great you know shadow band
was the original name for nwa we found
out some things about twitter and one of
the things they do is shadow band people
so they make it so that your your
content whatever you put out has less
impact it has it has less engagement
they limit your ability to express
yourself
they they ban accounts and they ban
accounts if the account says something
that they don't agree with if the
account says something that violates
what they believe
also this ability to uh shadow ban
people has to be exposed i'm sitting
here now and people are so concerned
about
elon musk owning twitter and i'm like
well
at least now we have accountability at
least now the buck stops with one guy so
like if you don't like whatever is
happening with twitter we know who owns
it now we know like hey he made the
choice he's in charge and then you can
decide you know what i don't want to be
on twitter see right now i think it's
better that we know everything
transparency because up to this point
right now who makes these policies at
twitter like who's in charge of the
day-to-day we have no idea at least now
there's a face so like if you feel like
hey this is too
left-leaning it's too right-leaning it's
too
uh there's too much hate speech just too
much whatever at least now we could be
like yo we can actually tweet at the guy
hey man what the hell is going on with
uh twitter i don't like this what about
all other platforms [ __ ] and
twitter not even a top 15 social media
app
it's not about whether it's top 15 or
not impact it has impact because it is
where the news is like that's where i
get my news and that's where washington
post poster news that's where the times
post the news that's where everybody
posts a news so if you look at where
news comes out right and where things
begin to trend right and i'm not talking
about stupid dance moves i'm talking
about like israel or happening actually
70 of all breaking news is on twitter
exactly so don't buy the new york times
buy the place the new york times breaks
the news which is on twitter no one goes
to new york times website they go to
twitter they see an article then they go
to new york times website so he's like
[ __ ] it i'll just own that thing and i
don't even need to control the news that
comes out i'll just be able to say
whatever i want and because i own it
[ __ ] talk about me we were
listening that jack dorsey guy right
yeah yeah the guy who owned it before
yeah why why are we listening to him why
do we care what he says because he's
rich and he owns two because he on
twitter well now this guy gave a [ __ ]
about tom and tom never even spoke i
wouldn't even know if tom was a real
person i don't
chelsea
from my space shouts to tom that's what
i'm saying about siri huh siri
what happened with cereal
i used to like that podcast
was great cereal was amazing
i think it's interesting that um
that elon is trying to buy twitter i
like it
you know i like to see
you know free speech has been it's not
what it used to be
it's not
um
you know in a lot of media it's all
owned by the same
couple of organizations and types of
people
and
um and you're not you're not allowed to
say certain things
you know i know on twitter they shut
down
certain political views and political uh
stories they won't even let them be
shared on there
uh whereas other ones they will
you know certain schools of thought and
and ideas they won't allow
and others they will
um
and it's a dump
it's a dump and it's just about power
and control
um
and people are sick of it people are i
mean it's literally making people sick
you know you take away somebody's voice
and it uh
for some of us all that's the only thing
you have that's yours
you know and i've been a victim of not
even i've been a pro i've been a
contributor of it myself and being
afraid to even say what i really want to
say sometimes
being afraid to speak up for myself
afraid that i won't be able to
that i lose my ability to even have a
job or have a space it's been a great
week
for elon musk
and all the white men celebrating
it is true i can't deny that i mean you
go on twitter and the white people they
have not been this happy
since like the rolling stones said they
were torn again
i mean it's a real
i mean white guys are really
you know they are really excited dude
it's like hockey season
they're very happy um because i guess
they feel like they've been
discriminated against
in this new culture where
calling someone a white guy is now
pejorative
in some sense if someone goes
if they go of course
i should have known
a white guy said it or i'm watching what
else would you expect from a white guy
all you got to do is replace the word
white guy with jew and you understand
how jew became a pejorative it's the
same exact way what do you think
he's doing this for what is the
inspiration behind this
i mean i know what people are hoping
that it is yeah like but what do you
think of this yeah i don't know i like i
mean i'm i just trust that he's like a
savvy business sort of like mover and
that he knows what he's doing kind of
what he wants the outcome to be but
i mean equity in some major platform in
terms of like you have all these
billionaires that buy up
like media companies so like bezos buys
up washington post like msnbc the ms is
microsoft you know i mean like it's
owned by all these media companies are
owned by billionaires so i'm assuming
he's looking at this is like oh this is
the new wave of media so i'm going to
try to buy in to the newest to the new
point that would be really [ __ ] smart
so
um were you going to say something else
i think he wants
twitter on the tesla interface
in cars
interesting for what reason he right now
he has spotify there's a few that he
doesn't have
and so i'm pretty sure they're blocking
him from like including them in there
because their interface is like you
can't adjust it oh really yeah but you
can't buy apps you can't add apps like
that yeah and then and so what would be
the advantage of having twitter on just
makes it more cool and exactly my cars
come with twitter
as you have self driving
that's interesting him being able to
like buy up or leaks buy shares of these
companies that he wants to incorporate
in the teslas i think that's kind of fun
but to what mark was saying i think is
quite interesting is that once you
become a billionaire you need a media
apparatus to protect your wealth and
it's not even billionaire like back in
the day you just need like jeff bezos
needs something that's pumping out
positive bazel [ __ ] yeah and crushing
his enemies i'll do it rupert murdoch
every single one of them so the media is
really an arm of the powerful and we've
seen that in terms of
powerful politicians but we also have to
look at it as in terms of like powerful
businessmen and in america the
businessmen and women you could argue
have just much influence in the
government as
the government what are we discussing
really when we talk about elon musk
owning twitter some people it seems
saying this is outrageous one person
owning twitter that's disgusting but
that's been going on for ages doesn't it
i mean doesn't one person own facebook i
know it's a privatized company and
they're shareholders but mark zuckerberg
i'm guessing has a kind of significant
influence over facebook so when people
talk about billionaires buying twitter
and it being wrong for a billionaire to
own to here i think what they're really
saying is i want one of my billionaires
to own and run twitter a billionaire
that's sympathetic to my opinions i was
having a conversation with a couple
friends yesterday about this and one of
them is dealing with comments on another
social media platform
and what they were saying was that
you know
what twitter does by banning people and
censoring people is definitely bad but
there are some [ __ ] horrible people
that were banned by twitter that are now
ruining these other social media apps
and they were explaining to me like
what's happening and how these people
comment on these other apps and about
how toxic they are and about they have
like a whole group of people that have
also been banned that find these new
social media apps and that's that's
where they congregate and hang out and
that's their community now and it's just
it's just chernobyl it's just toxic what
are the other apps well there's a
shitload of them i don't want to name
the one they're like this person was
talking to me about okay specifically
because i don't want to [ __ ] up because
i i think i believe in these other apps
i believe in
all these other alternative platforms
and i think that there's great value in
having competitors
whether it's to twitter or to youtube or
to any of these facebook any of these
giant
huge companies that have a massive
pipeline to the consciousness of the
world 44 billion
i'ma be honest with you i see this has
people in uh uh uproar people are
outraged they're up in arms
i
don't give a [ __ ] you know what i mean
and the reason i don't give a [ __ ] is
because it's a billionaire billionaire
yes what am i supposed to think about
this they act like this the end of the
world like what is going what am i
missing am i missing something nothing
can help they're just upset because
they're gonna be upset that's just what
they do and they need outrage [ __ ] so
they can get tweets etc i mean like of
course [ __ ] sean king found a way to
turn it into white supremacy elon musk
elon musk and elon musk and elon musk
this is a good time if you want to
commit a mass murder or you wanted to
take over a country or if you wanted to
get away with grooming or whatever evil
you're into right now do it because the
news is completely preoccupied with
weather we're returning to a nazi
digital landscape
uh joy what's your name joy reid what's
your name joy reid from msnbc
sean king are very concerned that uh
elon musk is a white supremacist and
twitter is now in the hands of a white
supremacist i haven't seen this tenuous
a connection between elon musk buying
twitter since
um
since the slap since hollywood's 911
where white supremacy was blamed for the
slap but hats off whenever you can try
to tie white supremacy to something i'm
always listening because i believe it's
entertaining and elon musk welcome to
the white supremacy crew my friend
because
you may not have been a white
supremacist before you bought twitter
but now that you're uh seeking to
enforce free speech
welcome to white supremacy club my
friend
the club is bigger it's like it's like
pronouns and bathrooms they grow every
day journalists are devastated to
imagine that a single rich person could
even try to walk in and upend their
project couldn't musk just leave twitter
in the hands of responsible speech
protecting shareholders like saudi
prince al-waleed bin talal right so if
your objections to musk are moral ones
then how do you feel about prince alawid
bin talal i've experienced vocal over
media censorship and criticism and
accusations of being a conspiracy
theorist one from a newspaper called the
independent that is also 50
owned by saudi arabian shareholders what
i think people really mean when they
attack someone is you don't agree with
me so shut up elon musk richest man in
the world and our favorite lesbian
stepdad needs to run twitter and not the
saudi royal family and here's why first
of all elon is the goat which is clearly
why the saudis are trying to [ __ ] him i
mean do we really want weekend at
burning yemen calling the shots at
twitter this saudi prince that looks
like wario just sniffed a little girl's
bicycle seat rejected elon's offer to
buy twitter he said elon's offer which
was 38 above the stock price was too
little what this guy must be dropping
acid and i'm not talking about on women
trying to drive
also
of course saudi arabia doesn't want elon
owning it okay they're furious at him
self-driving is a loophole to put women
behind the wheel we cannot let the
saudis control twitter okay it won't
last they have a history of crashing
things after hijacking them
wow
we need elon to buy twitter okay it's
something we can all agree with a rich
south african is trying to own something
that's not a person that is progress
speaking of progress woke people should
want this okay we need more
african-american businesses not to
mention we should support marginalized
groups and right now autistic african
americans are under attack
obviously proud boys are on board
they'll be able to say the n word
without posing as a black teenager
that's right proud boys you can type it
the way you vote with a hard r
elon's the bot for the job okay he's a
diamond in the rough and i'm not talking
about what he mined as a child
i mean the guy married a woman from
another planet and had kids with her he
can do anything
now unfortunately they broke up so
technically she's uh
i can't say it come on
no
i love corny do it
technically she's his spacex
[Music]
[Music]
you